[Music]
in a universe where heroes travel
through time
battle ungodly villains and come back to
life
as easily as they die a meaningful
relationship can bring
everything back into focus and that's
exactly what iris west does for barry
allen
but who is this mysterious woman out of
time
it's probably worth knowing that iris
west isn't like
any old superhero love interest she's
not a damsel in need of saving or a
simple shoulder to cry on in
fact iris story is deeply ingrained with
the strange
and knotted mythos of the flash the most
important thing to know about her
however
is that she comes from hundreds of years
in the future
see most people tend to think of the
flash as a guy who runs really fast
that feels like an oversimplification
indeed while that's not untrue
the truth is that a significant portion
of the flash universe is centered around
the idea of traveling through time
barry allen frequently journeys to the
past or future
to right wrongs or prevent great
atrocities often finding that his
meddling causes as many problems as it
solves
even the smallest change to the
timelines can have life-changing
consequences for barry
and the people he cares about 1971's the
flash number 203
provided a good example of barry allen's
chronological shenanigans
in which the speedster discovers that
his wife iris
is actually a time traveler from the
30th century
though different versions of the story
have her coming back in time
at different points in her life one of
the most prominent puts iris time travel
in her infancy leaving her with little
recollection of the far-off future
like barry iris west grew up in central
city different versions of the flash
have given her different occupations
over the years but her attraction to
berry remains pretty consistent
regardless of which continuity the story
happens to be in
most versions of iris have her working
for the central city newspaper as a
reporter which is how she meets barry
some iterations like the cw's flash
series
portray iris and berry as being friends
since childhood
in the television series barry was
essentially raised as a part of iris's
family
following the death of his mother who
was killed by the villainous eobard thon
no matter how they end up meeting
however barry and iris always seem to
end up together
and although they have their differences
they clearly love each other dearly
they were even engaged and eventually
married for a while in the comics
with iris finally learning that barry is
secretly the flash
about a year after they tied the knot
being in love with a superhero certainly
has its perks but it also inevitably
leads to great pain
too after all if you have an enemy who
has dedicated their entire life to
seeing you suffer
a non-superpowered loved one is
basically a flashing neon target
naturally with flash's nemesis reverse
flash looking to harm barry allen in
every possible timeline
it was only a matter of time before the
super villain tried to bring her down
too reverse flash isn't exactly one for
subtlety
but he was once able to find a way to
corner iris without sacrificing any of
his characteristic flair
in this story he finds barry's then wife
at a costume party
where he is cleverly disguised as
himself
iris meanwhile is dressed as batgirl a
character who has been attacked by more
than a few super villains herself
during the party reverse flash who is
then known as professor zoom
uses his speed powers to vibrate his
hand through iris's skull
scrambling her brain and killing her
instantly
though iris remains dead for a while in
barry's timeline
it's later revealed that she's actually
doing well elsewhere
in the meantime barry falls in love
again and zoom
true to form attempts to kill his next
fiance too
that's rude while iris is absent from
barry's life for quite some time
another iris exists further up the time
stream after yet another battle with
professor zoom
flash takes a trip into the future to
visit iris's birth parents
the russells who sent iris into the past
after enlisting the help of that era's
flash
john fox but things have gone wrong in
the 30th century
when iris died in the past it created a
paradox in their own time
luckily the wrestles were able to solve
the problem by putting the consciousness
of iris in another body
when flash visits the russells he meets
this new iris
and they quickly fall back into their
old ways with barry vowing to stay in
the 30th century for good
unfortunately a villain known as the
anti-monitor soon travels into the 30th
century and kidnaps barry
after bringing him back into his
original timeline the villain tortures
the flash as he sets about destroying a
number of different versions of
earth the flash finally breaks free of
his restraints and destroys the
anti-matter machine
at the heart of anti-monitor's plan but
the exertion of this feat
ultimately proves too much for barry who
was killed in the process
during berry and iris's month together
in the 30th century
iris becomes pregnant she eventually
gives birth to twins
who are also imbued with the power of
the speed force
named dawn and dawn the two children
become collectively known as the tornado
twins
and grow up to fight crime in their own
time until they're both killed in an
attack by the dominators
before dawn's death he has a child named
bart with melody thon
the descendant of professor zoom they
hope that their relationship will
finally put an
end to the eon spanning war between the
flash and zoom but the combination of
their superpower genetics creates a
child that ages far too
quickly out of concern for bart's
long-term health
iris travels back in time to seek a cure
for his condition
she teams up with wally west who is then
fighting crime under the mantle of the
flash
and finds the solution leading bart to
start his own super-powered vigilante
career as the hero known as
impulse as you might imagine
iris tends to feel deeply uncomfortable
living in the 20th century
being in an entirely new more primitive
time makes her uneasy to say the least
so she decides to go into hiding rather
than deal with the demands of 20th
century life
unfortunately it's hard to stay under
the radar when you hold the secrets of
the future
the history contained in her brain makes
her a massive target for villains hoping
to get one
over on their enemies when ira sticks
her neck out to help johnny quick
win a battle with the speed force
worshiping cult leader
savitar she ends up giving herself away
she is subsequently kidnapped by polaris
and abracadabra so that they might plot
world domination using her
insight when she manages to escape she
goes underground again
eventually publishing a history of the
flash from an undisclosed
location after becoming embroiled in a
case of mistaken identity
regarding wally west's supposed
illegitimate child
iris opts to come out of hiding and
spend more time with her family
iris's newfound family life is turned on
its head
by the flashpoint miniseries in this
massive line-wide event
barry allen realizes that he's woken up
in an alternate world
and is the only one who remembers life
as it's supposed to be
superman's place in the pantheon has
been taken up by cyborg
thomas wayne is not only not dead but
he's actually batman
meanwhile wonder woman and aquaman are
locked in a forever war
and the justice league doesn't even
exist in this reality iris west is
married to another reporter
though her nephew wally west still
exists he has nothing to do with the
speed force
and is eventually killed during the
events of the story in an attempt to set
the world right
barry and thomas wayne try to reawaken
his speed powers
so that he might fix the altered
timeline the first attempt goes poorly
to say the least and barry ends up
horribly burned the second attempt works
though it nearly kills wayne
and barry's powers are restored the
flash is later confronted by eobard thon
who reveals that the new timeline was
created by barry's attempt to go back in
time
and save his mother because the
resulting shift wrote him out of the
history of the flash
thon gloats that he could kill barry
without endangering his own timeline
after batman defeats thawne barry
successfully resets the universe
wiping out 10 years of dc cannon in the
process
in the wake of the flashpoint storyline
dc ruled out a hard reboot of their
titles
dubbed the new 52 this reset brought
back barry allen and started his story
from the beginning
before he was involved with iris in the
new 52 timeline her feelings for barry
get stronger
and stronger but unlike the old version
of the character
barry doesn't actually feel the same way
the new 52 was semi-abandoned
just five years later with the dc
rebirth event
this time around iris realizes that she
once lived another life
she sees visions of herself married to
barry allen and begins to understand
that the timeline has been altered
somehow
iris begins to uncover the events of
flashpoint and
when she realizes that barry is
responsible for altering the timeline
due to his frequent time travel
shenanigans
she starts to push him away iris knows
that barry is fully aware of the
differences that exist
in a post-flashpoint universe and that
he kept that knowledge from her
with some hard work and a decent apology
however
very is ultimately able to win back her
trust
the arrowverse version of the flash
picks and chooses portions of iris's
comic book backstory
while she remains a journalist in
central city other parts of her story
are less defined by comic history
wally west is her brother in the
television series for example and she's
not romantically involved with barry
at least not at first over the course of
the arrowverse flash series
iris positions herself as a crucial part
of the flash's world
indeed she's been more than explicit
about the importance of the non-powered
team
in barry's life you're human
and we have a purpose too we remind
superheroes what they're fighting for
over time she grows close to barry and
the pair eventually marry
she has a child with barry named nora
but in true flash fashion
the child turns out to be unstuck in
time and is subsequently raised by iris
entirely alone after barry winks out of
existence
iris then hides nora's speedster powers
by implanting a limiting chip in her
daughter and steering her away from
stories about her father
in time nora learns of her abilities and
grows resentful of iris
traveling back in time to join team
flash as an adult
and finally meeting her father for the
first time
over time nora west allen becomes
obsessed
with the super-powered serial killer
known as cicada
a villain that her late father never
caught when she travels back in time
she attempts to help her parents put a
stop to his crime spree
unfortunately mucking about in the time
stream alters the future so much
that nora herself ceases to exist before
she's erased from reality
nora is able to embrace iris and barry
one last time
the sudden loss of nora shakes iris
deeply but she doesn't have much time to
dwell on it
just one season later iris herself is
whisked out of the flash's universe
finding herself trapped in a dark
parallel universe
called the mirror verse while the flash
showrunners have revealed that iris will
return
from the mirror verse in season seven
she'll likely be deeply traumatized by
her time in that parallel universe
luckily if anything is clear about iris
west by now
it's that she always finds a way to
triumph over adversity
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies comics and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]